Let's
kick it off today with our caller from the
eight five six area code caller from eight
five six.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi David, this is Aaron from New Jersey.
Hey Aaron, what's going on?
Oh, I can't complain.
How are you today?
Good, thanks.
So today I was wondering with the rise of
the mutual movements we've seen the democratic
party specifically for especially rather,
um, go after men demonize men often times
when they haven't done anything wrong.
And you know, especially for someone like
me who is trying to find a girlfriend or a
wife, I feel like this environment that we've
created in a way is just coming back to haunt
us.
Um, a lot of times we can't even go and talk
to them and without being put on some sort
of watch lists or having some kind of side-eye
or comment going towards us.
So I guess my question to you is what is your
advice to someone who in this environment
is seeking someone to connect with?
Okay.
So let's, let's explore that Aaron.
How old a guy are you?
26.
Okay.
So your concern as a 26 year old, uh, am I
correct to understand that you're saying you're
a heterosexual male, you would conceivably
be interested in dating or marrying a woman,
right?
Right.
You are in a sense afraid of going to even
talk to women because you have seen other
men merely for talking to women, uh, be criticized
as either harassing them or given side-eye.
Am I understanding that correctly?
Yes.
And who would be an example of a man who talked
to a woman and was accused of sexual harassment,
for example?
Well, I think the most pony we became old
that we came, that we both know about it would
be Joe Biden who I've talked to you about
before.
But remember Lucy for us, the reason that
when she was interviewed, when she was asked
why she's coming out about this, she's saying,
Oh, the only reason that I came out about
this is because I want to put Bernie things
into the white house.
Now, see, this is exactly what I'm talking
about where if you don't look a certain way,
like if you don't have a channel that don't
lie under six back ups or in her case a socialist
or democratic socialist agenda Zooey you're
just uncleaned you're thinking we have to
go after you and put you in jail or something.
Right.
And Aaron, so the example of, uh, an alleged
political vendetta being used to criticize
Joe Biden to prop up Bernie Sanders, that
affects you as a 26 year old looking for a
girlfriend.
How, again,
I think it feeds the narrative.
I think that, I mean I have other examples
I can pull up from my personal life, but I
think that like even when I do approach women,
a lot of the times it is new.
I will say, Hey, how's it going?
I think we can both agree that that's a fairly
normal inappropriate way to greet somebody.
Right?
Sure.
Well that'll be fine though.
A while ago, like I was getting paid back
or you know, maybe we started conversation,
but now people just look at like I'm scum,
like I'm not even worth living.
This is interesting.
So Aaron, as a 26 year old, would you say
that there was a period during which you were
having a lot of dating success?
Yeah, I would say so.
I would say now things have just changed to
an extent.
Okay.
But hold on, hold on.
Listen, I want, I'm trying to talk through
it.
There was a point.
How old were you when you would say that when
you with your, Hey, how's it going?
You would go up to women and it would go really
well.
Like how long ago was that?
Hmm.
I'd say about four or five years.
Okay, so you were, you were, were you in college
at the time?
Yeah.
And where'd you go to school?
Okay.
Um, prominent universities, not too far away,
but um, it wasn't really a university where
this would happen.
It would just be, you know, going out.
I'm holding out at the park, going for a run,
just anywhere.
So when you were 20, you would hang out at,
hold on.
When you were 20, you would hang out at a
park and meet women by saying, Hey, how's
it going?
Oh yeah.
You know, see them on the, on the trail weaning
the supermarket or whatever
on the in the supermarket.
Who would be going, you know, Aaron, I'm having
a hard time believing your story.
It sounds very weird.
What sounds rude about it?
It just sounds like you're not even really
sure what it is you're claiming happened or
is happening.
The, your, you were meeting women at parks
when you were 20.
I mean, it's just, doesn't, it doesn't it
all sound a little bit strange?
I don't think there's a bad place to meet
someone.
If I see someone I like to talk to, I just
[inaudible].
And now, now where you're getting the bad
looks, when you say, Hey, how's it going?
Is it still happening at parks and supermarkets
or is it happening somewhere else?
You know, I, I have gotten discouraged on
if I don't do it anymore cause I feel like
we're going into direction where if you do
talk to them and we're moving in the direction
where you will be positive to the full extent.
But hold on a second, Aaron, when you first
got on the phone, you said that since the
me too movement became prominent, when you,
whenever you go up to women and do this and
say, Hey, how's it going?
They react as if you're doing something wrong.
But then now when I asked you where that's
happening, you said you're not even going
up to women anymore.
So, which is it?
Is that you're having trouble now when you
go up to women or you're just choosing not
to do it at all because those are two different
things.
Right.
Well that's discouraged me.
I don't think a very good response.
So I, I, I'm trying to look for some hopes
here.
I want to know what your advice is.
My advice would be not to call people up with
fake stories and instead just work on being
a normal person.
My friend.
I'm going to let you go.
Okay.
I don't believe any of it.
All right.
Thanks.
Take care.
Aaron from New Jersey.